[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on appelle frapper fort à
l'origine de cette campagne pour une
éducation sans violence la fondation
pour l'enfance dénonçant une pratique
partagée par plus de 80% des français
qui se gifle de génération en génération
par tous
cette campagne est une nécessité tous
les pays européens on fait comme ça une
campagne pour accompagner la loi loi
justement proposé en 2010 par edwige
antier pédiatre et députée visant à
interdire toute violence physique ou
psychologique des parents sur leurs
enfants il faut savoir que la fessée ça
ne donne pas d'autorité au contraire ça
l'a fait perdre l'enfant vous braves
ensuite et l'enfant dissimule il devient
sournois de très nombreuses études l'ont
montré donc l'autorité ça ne passe pas
par la main levée
l'autorité ça fasse par guy d un enfant
léveillé l'accompagner et savoir dire
exclusion en trop c'est trop
bien sûr vous ne devez pas être laxiste
mais en tapant vous êtes laxiste vous
retombez vous même en enfance je tape
tape on crie c'est pas l'autorité une
vilaine habitude interdite ensuite
depuis 1979
suivi depuis par 21 pays européens la
france c'est en elle-même en principe
engagée en 2008 à abroger les châtiments
corporels
la loi n est pas là pour punir les gens
elle est là pour édicter une règle du
jeu pour affirmer l'importance d'une
valeur en l'espèce ne pas frapper les
enfants et pour jouer un rôle de
pédagogie du point de repère et de
pédagogie et niveau pédagogie il y a du
boulot quand on voit le succès
médiatique des gifles assénées par des
hommes politiques de françois bayrou au
socialiste jérôme cahuzac perçu comme de
véritables héros
bonsoir une gifle une baffe appelons la
comme on veut ce soir c'est une paire de
claques qui fait débat celle qu un élu
du sud ouest a donné un jeune homme qui
l'insultait l'autorité est elle à ce
prix
chacun se fera son idée interdire gifles
et fessées un combat risible pour
certains est difficile à mener en plein
retour de la discipline et de l'autorité
on mélange autorités violence on mélange
l'autorité répression alors que
l'autorité ça devrait d'abord prestation
et on a tout faux alors est ce que c'est
ça le modèle de vie que l'on se propose
dans nos rapports avec nos enfants mais
alors après dans le modèle de société ça
veut dire que le bas de la hiérarchie
doit respecter le corps intermédiaire
parce qu'on a peur de la sanction le
corps intermédiaires de respectives cour
supérieure parce qu'il a peur de la
sanction le corre super et de respecter
le uniquement parce qu'on a peur de
recevoir une gifle un avancement ou de
recevoir une fessée une mutation
c'est ça le débat
emmanuel piette natacha polony bonsoir
nous allons voir un reportage de céline
jeudi à propos de la polémique suscitée
par le clip et la campagne éduquons sans
violence ni claques ni fessées un spot
choc pour faire réagir et provoqué un
débat sur la question de la violence et
éducative c'est réussi puisque nous
sommes là ce soir
gifles et fessées faut-il y renoncer
j'ai souhaité en parler avec vous
mesdames vous et votre quête vous êtes
médecin de protection maternelle et
infantile vous êtes présidente du
collectif féministe contre le viol
vous êtes la coordinatrice la campagne
contre la violence éducative mise en
place par la fondation pour l'enfance
vous êtes donc à l'origine de ce fameux
spot alors je vous pose la question la
question titre gifles et fessées
faut-il renoncer dix réponses courtes
russe pour vous annoncer voilà bon c'est
dit c'est dit vous natacha polony
journaliste essayiste spécialiste des
questions d'éducation
vous avez un blog éloge de la
transmission sur lesquels vous avez
réagi à cette campagne avec un article
intitulé sos enfants battus et société à
la dérive donc la même question pour
vous gifles et fessées faut-il y renonce
je crois qu'il faut surtout différencier
rien que gifles et fessées ce n'est pas
la même chose et ne parlons pas des
violences et des maltraitances
alors on va commencer par revenir sur ce
clip vous en avez abondamment en parler
vous l'avez commenté alors qu'avez vous
pensé de ce clip
et sachez que le débat se déroule entre
vous oui j'ai trouvé quand j'ai regardé
ce clip qu'il était d'abord
mal fait dans le sens où la situation
n'est pas crédible
or je trouve que sur un sujet comme ça
voir cette gamine totalement calme dans
ce cadre idyllique qui tout à coup tout
sa main pour faire tomber un jus de
fruit
la mère qui tout cas qu'on pique une
crise d'hystérie tulle ça ne colle pas
avec la réalité et je crois que ça ça
présente un défaut majeur qui est en
fait de mettre sur le même plan des
comportements qui sont totalement
différent c'est à dire que il ya en
france des enfants qui sont victimes de
maltraitance
il y a des enfants martyrs il ya des
enfants qui sont battus des enfants qui
sont maltraités même psychologiquement
mais physiquement les coups de ceinture
ça existe encore et c'est cela qu'il
faut cibler or là en assimilant ces
choses là avec une claque dont on ne
sait pas d'où elle sort totalement
hystérique encore une fois tout ça sur
le même plan je crois qu'on est en train
de perdre de vue que justement on n'est
pas capable de traiter correctement la
maltraitance que vivent certains enfants
souvent ils passent à l'as on ne les
repèrent pas mais quel côté de ça on est
en train d'envoyer un message aux
parents qui est un message qui
brouillent totalement les pistes puisque
ça leur interdit de savoir exactement
quelles sont les limites
et quelle est leur responsabilité en
gros en leur disant 3-1 fassiez vous
êtes des bourreaux on n'a pas de
culpabiliser ceux qui maltraitent et
l'objectif de la place pas été du tout
faire une campagne contre la
maltraitance ça on sait faire et on fera
mais honnête justement souhaité faire
une campagne contre les publicités et
les punitions corporelles dit educating
celle qu'on voit dans le clip c'est la
claque qu'on donne et que des tas de
gens donne parce que le gosse a traversé
la route et qu'on a eu peur parce qu'on
est rentré énervé du boulot et que
patron avait agacé et que donc ça tombe
pour n'importe quoi c'est la caq rafle
est idiote parce qu'on n'est pas
contents et samuel c'est justement il ya
quand même dans le clip une autre
explication c'est le fait que la
personne qui pas ici
alors delaizir on a pensé au moment où
on a commencé à penser l'éducation qu'on
allait donner à ses enfants qu'il était
possible de les frapper
quelle que soit la façon dont on les
frappe et quand on dit une fessée ça
fait pas mal
en france les 50% des enfants ont déjà
reçu des fessées à moins 300 et penser
qu'on peut taper un petit ou même avec
une petite plaque sur la ma même une
petite tape sur les doigts même une
petite taxe sur la couche quand on est
une grande personne d'ahmed 70 et qu'on
a un tuyau qui fait 2 mois de mai et ben
ça fait très peur parce que c'est
accompagnée de gestes d'un regard assez
désagréable et parce qu'on pense que ça
va servir à quelque chose mais le gamin
lui il est terrorisé par quelqu'un de
très grands et qui est très mécontent et
ça ça fait peur
le gazon n'est pas terrorisé encore une
fois là il ya un mélange c'est à dire
que quelqu'un qui tape réellement un
petit moins de trois ans bien sûr que
c'est certain que pour ça on sait pas
quelqu'un c'est intéressant on dépensait
pts à ses enfants - trois noms ils ne
tapent pas justement s'est laissé
enfermer dans les brosses je vis
prosodie la tap ou fait comme ça par un
géant un degas entre 5 et 10 4 mètres il
se contrôle quand même je suis désolé je
suis désolée la question c'est est ce
qu'on se contrôler ou asus qu'on ne se
contrôle pas est-ce qu on se défoule sur
un enfant de brasser un enfant débat
qu'est ce qui l'expliqué
blanchet qui est gratuite enfants faut
se rendre à deux ans et croyez vous
qu'un
deux ans comprend absolument tous les
raisonnements que je vende bidonné les
gentils parents qui veulent absolument
lui expliquer pendant deux heures il
faut oublier qu'il ya des choses qu'il
faut pas faire c'est tout
en effet en disent non et on pose une
limite si cet enfant transgresse la
limite parce qu'il la plupart des
ménages s'est pas prononcé sur le fond
soit un enfant comprend très bien la
preuve qu'il ya besoin d'un gars à la
mort de deux ans on pourra besoin d'un
écart est de la france sont et
d'apprendre à bien ce truc à saïda quand
le gamin quand on sait que les grands ça
tape et toutes les études montrent que
les enfants les plus abîmées sont ceux
qui ont subi les plus grande violence
alors c'est lui c'est bien mon service
vous revenez à la maltraitance
alors c'est différent sur la question
des faits sont lgd bien efficace
inefficace sont-elles traumatisante
est-ce que vous parlez vous parlez
d'études sur le sujet mais si les
enfants qui ont été traumatisés par ce
qu'ils ont pris une ou deux fessées à
des moments où les parents maîtrisent
est ce qu'il faut j'ai dit non les
enfants sont traumatisés parce qu'il est
lié à des violences psychologiques au
diable entre ce qu'on fait quand on tape
un enfant qu'est ce que ça veut dire
quand on sait maîtriser ce mépris dre
quand on tape un enfant de deux ans et
demi qu'est ce que ça a comme sens pour
l'enfant qu'est ce qu'ils en font
saliver amstrong la peur la médiation à
se planquer à il apprend qu'il ya des
limites à ne pas franchir ce pas comme
ça et si on a tous ce moyen là pour
apprendre et venue de jean faure on est
quand même assez fort mesdames c'est
loupé il ya d'autres espaces d'autres
pays la situation est différente on sait
par exemple que les pays où 28 pays vous
le dit d'ailleurs dans le clip on
interdit d'afficher qu'est ce que cela a
changé puisqu'on parle études
qu'est ce que cela a changé sur
l'éducation et le comportement des
enfants si on en sait quelque chose
alors qu'avant je connais bien la suède
parce que c'est ils ont interdit la
fessée en 76
donc ça fait plus de trente ans et je me
souviens que ce que je suis vieille
quand ils ont commencé à faire ça en
france au dîner pourront pas les élever
son peuple allait taper ce qui est
d'ailleurs assez extraordinaire parce
que c'était impossible
et quand on
vingt ans après ils ont évalué cette loi
et il y avait 80 % des suédois qui
considérait la punition corporelle comme
l'on tait non éducative alors que ici on
fait le même sondage les français ils
sont 52% comme bouée de calais pourtant
toute société scandinave absolument
merveilleuse ont quand même des types
qui rentre dans des écoles et qui
trucide de 30 personnes donc excusez moi
mais la société label halal ericsson
pour les messages jusqu'à preuve du
contraire on la faim ont franchi peu à
maintenant je veux dire que c'est pour
comparer et donc la fessée quand même
pas traumatisé à ce point là mais c'est
surtout que c'est une question encore
une fois de de gradation de réflexion
leurs limites à beaumont il a levé vers
le social comme les bouteilles qui
veulent associer à votre enfant
la question est de savoir comment on
éduque en employant recommande d'aller
donner les allées construit en tant
qu'être humain quand la galère d'abord
commencé un gainage transe à quel âge et
qui est là ils transgressent village
alors mais c'est parce qu'on pense à
canach chère madame
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que vous
ne les aviez c'est moi mais je ne pense
pas vraiment laconique voudrait mais je
sais pas par dessus de la cage aux lions
c'est trop ordinaire afin que vous ne
réfléchissez pas en termes individuel
c'est à dire que vous êtes en train de
servir aux gens un discours d'experts
qui serait valable tout le temps dans
toutes les situations pour tout le monde
au lieu de donner à des parents
l'intelligence d'éduquer correctement
leurs enfants et c'est ça qui me dérange
en fait c'est cette espèce de dogmes qui
remplace la capacité des paroles à le
faire des choix à savoir ce qu'il doit
faire et ce qu'ils doivent s'interdire
absolument le faire et vous replacer sa
part une espèce d'interdiction globale
qui finalement groupe totalement les
cartes encore une fois et leur interdit
de savoir qu'il ya des choses
inacceptables qu'il y a des choses
ensuite qu'ils peuvent faire de temps en
temps même si elles sont répréhensibles
par exemple craquer et s'énerver et
frapper un enfant c'est répréhensible
c'est mauvais mais ça je pense que ça
arrive à beaucoup de parents oui seront
menées à toi est ce qu'on la soigne les
ciel et blanc aura été sa vie sa
tablette la question c'est de justement
de savoir comment ses parents peuvent se
réapproprier l'éducation de leurs
enfants
c'est à dire je
comment comprendre que laisse
l'essentiel est de se maîtriser de
l'essentiel est de savoir ce qu'on fait
l'élève les enfants parce qu'on a essayé
des enfants haïtiens en glisse derrière
et en faire vous croyez personne ne se
construit n'est capable de juger
l'éducation qu'il a reçue une et les
votes dans les années passent pour la
juger entre marie roy a généré annick et
qu'on soit 10 appareils non j'ai pas dit
ça si vous m'écoutez pas choisi qu'on
élève ses enfants avec l'enfant qu'on a
été si on a été avec battu chez les gens
qui disent de moi j'en ai vraiment pris
des claques n'était pas poussé j'avais
la ronde c'était pas grave je ferai pas
pareil jeffrey combs actuellement je
vois là une fois de plus vous y revenez
ou jeudi alors que faut il faire des
gens nous nous écoute
si on ne peut pas administrer ou plaques
ou fait c'est approprié
que faut-il faire le problème des gens
c'est de pas mettre de limites aux
enfants et 6 il vient un peu une minute
penser qu'en tapant des pieds en
braillant les risques de faire c'est des
mamans ou papas et ben il va le faire ça
je pense que c'est quand même assez
logique mais s'assure sur la caisse sur
cette question je vous rejoins
totalement bien sûr que c'est avant
qu'il faut les limites on est
entièrement d'accord sauf que vous
pouvez pas exclure le fait c'est pas
une perte de contrôle mais vous ne
pouvez pas exclure le fait qu' il ya des
moments où même quand on a donné des
limites à un enfant justement il va
chercher à aller plus loin et merci à
vous avez droit encore une fois je n'ai
pas de défendre les voulait pas d'un
julien la question de plus grand plus
fort puisque justement il y a une
différence dans les jeux mais on n'est
pas d'adultes fasse un adulte de là on
est face à un enfant à qui il faut
enseigner qu'il ya des choses qui ne se
font pas alors évidemment je vous
rejoins ça doit être rare et c'est pour
ça qu'on est bien d'accord que les
limites se place avant et les ont mis à
part ça j'ai suis désolé dans la réalité
d avoir un enfant dépasse ses limites
les humiliations et de la science est
justement c'était la question que je
vous pose est face à des situations où
même on à élever son enfant de telle
manière que normalement les choses ne
devrait pas survenir elles surviennent
avant que fait-on
elles surviennent que fait-on je veux
dire que y'a plein de gens pour donner
une claque mon pc et puis voilà et mais
l'idée c'est quand même de se
positionner et moi par exemple joffre
très volontiers le livre d'olivier morel
l'a fait ces eaux
aux personnes qui viennent d'accoucher
et c'est parce que c'est au moment où
l'enfant se présente qu'on va se
positionner sur est ce que je peux faire
autrement que en gardant des parce que
on est parent on doit d'abord respecter
la sécurité des enfants ensuite leur
apprendre les limites l'autonomie et
c'est pas une urgence à chaud et donc
dans le dans l'urgence à gérer il ya des
tas d'autres façons de faire on peut
bien sûr les très petits faut détourner
l'attention se dire que par exemple nous
on travaille par exemple activer le
personnel des crèches
ils ont ils ont
trente ans fort de deux moines trois ans
ils ont pas le droit de taper dessus une
chance et ben pote le monde valais va
taper sur un gosse et qu'il est un peu
loin et c'est bien on peut il faut
détourner l'attention
on peut crier on peut faire les
marionnettes on peut donc voilà il ya
des c'est possible puisque en crèche on
ne tape pas les enfants et on arrive
quand même à ce qu'il fallait c'est
qu'il soit en sécurité etc
puis après c'est vrai que jusqu'à 2 3
ans les équipes et les grands romans
d'explication c'est pas très fonctionnel
donc est certainement quelque chose
autour de changer les idées détournées
et moi je crois beaucoup à l'humour on
est dans une espèce et c'est drôle
d'ailleurs dans une espèce à la fois de
monde idéal de monde fictif
c'est à dire que l'humour les machins
enfin je vous bien minutes mais prenons
d'écart contre concret
pour les familles parce que dans la vie
réelle ça ne se passait pas comme ça les
enfants qu'il faut une grosse comme cela
mais je suis et ce que je n'arrive pas à
comprendre c'est comment vous pouvez
tenir ce discours sans voir que
malheureusement encore une fois dans un
monde idéal c'est très bien c'est très
sympathique mais dans la réalité ce que
vous êtes en train de faire c'est
d'expliquer aux gens uniquement parce
claque pas de fessées rien et ils seront
totalement démunis est incapable de
résister au lieu de titrisation demande
à la fin donc on culpabilise les parents
et en fait on ne leur donne pas de
véritable solution alternative parce que
je suis navré ce que vous proposez là la
plupart des gens en sont incapables
nous ne saurons pas le gérer ils ne
seront pas comment faire et se
retrouveront démunis et donc ils vont
faire quoi et de nouveau cédé devant
leurs enfants et ils vont se sentir
impuissant ou alors ils vont frapper mal
au mauvais moment
vous voyez au lieu de encore une fois le
faire a confié au célèbre bien là je
m'agace 60 pour bien tapé puisque vous
vous êtes intelligente et pragmatique
allez on tape à partir de lui c'est
henri jean thomas da mais simplement moi
je suis là parce que l'idéal d'une
société sans cesse de développer
l'intelligence
source c'est d'essayer de développer
leurs bons chances et leur liberté et
d'arrêter de leur imposer des discours
totalement culpabilisateur à une époque
où justement nous sommes confrontés à
une plutôt une carence de limite qu'à un
excès moi j'ai pas dit que tu allais pas
de limite je dis que c'est pas la bonne
méthode de l'étape et pour leur donner
limite c'est tout vous avez vous avez
développé chacune votre point de vue les
gens qui nous regardent bon quand ils
seront confrontés aux situations qui
peuvent amener les comportements dont on
a parlé prenons des décisions
je pense en leur âme et conscience en
tant que parents et puis ça arrive de se
tromper aussi en tout cas merci beaucoup
[Musique]